skeletons painted faces and lots of
sweet treats no it's not Halloween its
Dia de los Muertos for Day of the Dead
Day of the Dead is a holiday celebrated
in Mexico in some parts of Latin America
that honors and commemorates death it
combines indigenous rituals with the
Catholic holidays of All Souls and All
Saints Day it's believed that the
spirits of the dead are allowed to visit
their families on October 31st and leave
on November 2nd candles and flowers
lined the cemeteries of streets to guide
loved ones to their homes during that
time families and friends prepare food
make altars and decorate gravestones to
pay respects to the deceased parades are
held in children eat candies to
celebrate the lives once lived